thème c'est florent pagny est revenu sur
le départ de mme enel de the voice
visiblement le choix de la candidate n'a
pas plu à à florange à florent pagny qui
accuse même tf1 elle a pris une décision
de ne pas revenir mais elle avait quand
même enregistré ses performances donc ce
n'est pas elle qui a pris la décision de
ne pas passer les performances et la
chaîne qui a pris la décision
moi je pense qu'il fallait passer les
performantes il a aussi émis quelques
doutes au sujet de la production qui
aurait pu se laisser influencer
pourquoi d'un seul coup d'autres
personnes à l'extérieur viennent
d'imposer quelque chose alors qu'il n'y
a rien non plus de 6 dramatique au sujet
des découpes au montage il dit que c'est
pas son histoire
florent pagny de sainte-hermine sa
dernière saison de the voice ne
reviendra pas pour une nouvelle saison
et donc men elle va faire son retour à
la télé la candidate de the voice qui
avait quitté l'aventuré à cause de la
polémique sur ses propos tenus sur
twitter au sujet des attentats en france
annoncé qu'elle allait bientôt faire son
retour sur les réseaux sociaux également
alors ce poste au grain il parle
maintenant ce que vous êtes d'accord à
l'étranger y parle maintenant les et de
cette affaire à quoi trois mois on n'a
pas entendu avant qu'ils quittent les
missions et les mêmes pas ici dit il
ouvre sa bouche
excusez moi pour ça un peu tard de 14
juin comme on dit en jeu sur plus
indulgents que vous parce que avant les
directs il repart toujours à l'étranger
c'est vrai qu'il est tout suivi jules il
règne à tf1 une atmosphère crépusculaire
[Applaudissements]
alors à milan et enfin de rennes elle va
s'arrêter mais ne jurait que les jurés
devraient supporte plus les uns les
autres
il balance sur la production mais vous
vous rendez compte c'est incroyable moi
je suis sidéré par florent pagny ce
monsieur se permet tout perche aux
médias mais il est peut-être suber
l'adoré les bruits mais là je le trouve
j'emploie le mot déloyale du mal à
rester tout suspense encore mais en
c'est l'émission qui est quand même
michel bastos et des maisons nos sa
longueur de mes missions cécile 6,18 des
béninois
il ya peu ce qu'ils pensent ça fait un
peu de bien bonnes alors la peine ce
qu'on sait pas du tout qui sont
d'affirmer belge coucou est ce que vous
dites ce qu'il a raison de dire mme à la
production aurait dû l agc ment pas
c'est ça la question c'est juste les
propos d'un homme sur le départ il est
en conflit avec la production de ce vote
il est en conflit ouvert avec tf1 il
sait très bien qu'il va pas resigner
pour une prochaine saison et que
l'émission a train de péricliter
donc là il balance il les charges